you guys tell me I mean if I'm wrong
here but I don't think there's ever been
a fundraiser that started asking for
$100,000 and ended up asking for four
million dollars each time with some new
little stretch goal some new little
stretch goal each one being a little bit
more than the last one I've just never
seen anything like this
I you know I made this gift in the last
video and I thought you know I wonder if
that's a bit of a cheap shot but now I
don't think it is if you don't know guys
Londyn real on April 21 like literally a
few weeks ago he just started his
digital freedom platform I was only
asking for $100,000 now that goal was
quickly met and stretch goals were
created because oh we got to raise more
money we got to raise money through the
end of the deadline here because we're
only fund raising till the rose extreme
which was their big event and we'll just
keep fundraising and we'll put it
towards new goals and then we'll cut the
fundraising off this is gonna go on for
another ten days until Rose Ike and
we're shutting off we're we gonna be
closing down this fundraising campaign
very soon so again we're closing this
thing out on May 3rd we're not gonna
keep taking all your money we know we
know this looks kind of bad but we're
just gonna keep raising money to the end
of the fundraiser and they did that and
they raised a million dollars and we've
covered that in another video but now
guys and I can't believe I didn't see
this coming London real now wants
another three million dollars for the
digital freedom platform and no I'm not
kidding you you couldn't make this up if
you tried but now London real hit after
saying that he was cutting off the
fundraising will work cutting off the
fundraising in previous videos not even
a few weeks old now he's asking for 250
do it two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a month from the London real
army in order to maintain the platform
oh yes even though the platform is just
dailymotion in to cast no no no now we
need another quarter of a million
dollars a month for the decks do all
right
in order to do this because you know
what $100,000 won it wasn't enough
I don't know hundred thousand dollars
wasn't enough in fact it seems like
pittance now that won't even cover one
month of the digital freedom platform a
million dollars wasn't enough now Brian
Rose is asking for a total of four
million dollars from his followers all
to be raised now do these followers get
anything besides a t-shirt a few things
like this do they actually get any stake
in this platform that they're literally
but you know spending all their money on
no you guys let me know what you think
of this we're gonna keep this short see
in the next one that was phase one now
we're doing phase 2 phase 3 phase 4 and
lastly why are you doing this and why
are you doing this and this doesn't seem
right guess what I can't tell you
everything if I had told you everything
Sunday wouldn't have happened so
unfortunately even sometimes I have to
kind of head-fake you a little bit